Congressman George Santos well I feel
like I know you
um you've become this extraordinarily
well-known Global figure albeit not
necessarily for the reasons you may have
wanted how are you dealing with all this
attention you know Pierce becoming even
well known wasn't ever uh uh a desire
right I ran for office to be a
legislator not to be a quasi celebrity
as we jokingly say all the time
Washington DC is Hollywood for ugly
people but right uh it's it's just been
an adjustment but just trying to get the
work done look the media is going to
give me all this coverage what I'll do
is I'll use it to the advantage of
uplifting my legislative priorities for
the American people so that's how we're
we're I'm going to try to use that to my
advantage at this point how are you
dealing with the complete loss of your
anonymity now what's it been like for
you to be George Central summer streets
in America well it's it's uncomfortable
uh think about it this way just last
night we my husband and I went out to
the movies and you know as I'm walking
from
getting the tickets to get to the
concession stand to get to the theater
that Whispers all across the movie
theater so it's just very strange you
know because part of you like it as much
as part of he finds it uncomfortable I
can't stand it and a lot of people think
I love it I just can't stand it it's
something I'm going to have to learn how
to deal with because as as you said
earlier when we were talking uh before
taping once that Genie is out of the
bottle right you can't put it back in so
you need to learn how to live with it
and just that's what I'm doing if you'd
known what was going to happen to you in
terms of the ferocity of the attention
you know you're currently you've got
eight different official investigations
into you you know people have called you
the biggest liar in the world you know
all this stuff if you'd known what was
going to happen would you have still
wanted to run for office absolutely not
absolutely not so me running for office
was me trying to be a good servant to
the American people me giving back what
I've been able to to reap as a reward
from you know just the greatest country
on Earth and I know we can disagree
agree to disagree on that second
greatest we succeeded so I think we're
it's the greatest country on Earth and
I'm very thankful for it so I just
wanted to give back but if I knew that
it would come at this cost of
sacrificing my safety at many cases and
and my honor my privacy I wouldn't have
done it
like I said you're well known now around
the world in the UK people know you but
it's not for the reasons like I said I
suspect you would have wanted
let me just ask you I guess directly who
is the real George Santos I mean you've
even used a number of pseudonyms in the
past
um who is the real George Santos so it's
a it's a great question my name is
George Anthony devolder Santos pretty
long name
um and I've gone by Anthony my entire
life almost because my mother called me
Anthony I was her chosen name dispute of
parents of what to name the child so I
ended up with two first names two last
names but George Santos is I'm just a
regular person Pierce I'm flawed like
every other human being I've made
mistakes I've made strides I've
accomplished something that not many
people are able to accomplish which is
to come from abject poverty and be able
to make something and work something out
for themselves I have to sit down and
endure people say things about me that
are absolutely not true or they're just
making out of cloth because it fits a
narrative or some desperate journalist
trying to make a career off for
themselves off of my name today this is
what I've I've become subject of
desperate journalism journalists trying
to build a journalistic career for them
all right let me stand up for the media
please do you've also been subject to
proper interrogation because you're a
congressman of course you're one of the
most important political figures in
America as any serving congressman is
and what the media has done is they've
looked into your background looked into
your life and they found a number of
things which simply aren't true
we'll go through some of it a little
later but I'm not sure blaming the media
will fly particularly in your defense
because the media's done its job you may
not like it it might be bruising it
might be ferocious I don't I think when
the American Media comes you as a
politician there's nothing quite like it
in the world outside of the probably the
British media
um so I'm not pretending for a moment
it's been easy for you but I do think
it's a bit lame to blame the media
they've done their job and you if I'm
honest have made it easy for them of
course look I'm not saying they're not
doing their job there's a difference
between doing their job and a difference
between making a Witch Hunt out of
something
the moment the story broke from the one
from the New York Times it took me three
days it was right around Christmas after
on the 26th of December I sat on with
the New York Post had an hour-long
interview they decided to go out with
barely any if anything of what I told
him and just continue to go under the
down spiral assumptions I've tried to
sit with many members of the media like
I'm doing with you now and have a
thorough conversation but they're just
not interested they're not interested in
covering de facto what actually occurred
what actually what are facts well I am I
am and all I would urge you to be is you
may as well be completely honest now of
course because I don't say there's any
upside in continuing to fuel the media
narrative that you're this terrible liar
right so you know I'm very I listen I
don't have a horse in the race I'm not
an American citizen you're not my
congressman you don't serve me it's not
my hard-earned cash going on supporting
you so in that sense I'm slightly
detached from this all I can say is in
the UK we're aware of you because
there's been this constant running theme
now for months on end that you tell a
lot of Whoppers as we would call it in
the UK and so I think it's a good it's a
good chance Congressman to just try and
work out where the truth lies because
why not
um
there's a claim that you said you
attended the Horace Mann school in the
Bronx New York during your first years
of high school but had to leave in your
senior year because your parents fell on
Hard Times in 2008. is that true Did you
attend that school I attended it for a
brief period of time and then went back
to the public school system and then
dropped out of the public school system
and attained a GED I was always very
truthful of not completing High School
due to financial difficulties I mean
spokesman for the school told CNN
there's no record of you ever attending
why would that be I I challenge to see
what their what name they're looking
under if you look at my entire history
of education it was not under the name
George Santos so what name did you
attend that of a variation it was either
George devold or Anthony the volder I
wouldn't know I was a minor I don't know
what you're CNN I believe checked all
the variants of the names that you've
used and there was no record the school
could find of you ever attending I was
there for six months of ninth grade in
what year would that have been uh 2000
four so for six months you were
indisputably at the Horus man school and
then moved into and then moved into the
public system and then in 2006 I
attained a GED due to just circles why
would the school not be able to find a
recorder I don't know
what name should they be looking for I
would say George defolder that's how I
that's how it's on my uh GED certificate
you got on the George devilda Anthony
defolder well officially the only two
names I've ever used on documentation
has been George defolder or George
Santos so there should be a record of
one of those at that school of course
the second claim was on the on the
campaign website that you graduated with
a degree in economics and finance from
Baruch College in 2000. I'll say I'll
save you the I did not attain a college
education that was that was that
regrettably so is one of my biggest uh
uh regrets in life so that that was a
lie absolutely and I admitted to it and
I've I've made peace with the fact that
I made a bad choice in making that
decision it wasn't easy what's the
simple explanation for why you met why
would you lie about something like that
expectation on society the pressure
couldn't afford it uh decided I wanted
to run for office although I had built a
very credible business career and I just
didn't have that part of my biography
that I could not give anything did you
not think that you'd be cool
you know
I just went with it I I didn't I mean if
you're going to make up a lie are you
thinking at all I just think it was a
stupid decision in my part very stupid
decision that I regret every day
especially because I can so sorry to cut
you off but especially because I can
prove the chops and the backing without
the education but this stems more deeper
into the political apparatus and the
political culture of New York State and
that would take a lot more time than
this program to go over to explain
I understand the desire to want to be
more impressive with your record than
you are I I'm bemused that you would be
naive enough to think that you could run
as a politician in New York in
particular and not expect to get what
happened to you which is a massive
comeuppance when they discover this
stuff isn't true stupid
stupid you claimed on your resume to
have gained a Masters in Business at New
York University
with a GMAT of 710
which would indicate academic Excellence
but that's not true right well the
reality is they don't know where that
GMAT comes from I I never put that out
on my website or my bio but you didn't
get a Masters in Business no no but I'm
just saying that the GMAT was on your
resume I think which the resume was
never furnished or supplied by me who
supplied I have no idea where that came
from someone did it on your behalf I'm
not saying no I I didn't Supply it and
nobody associated with me supplied it
that came from the GOP and I'm still
trying to understand where that came
from but you never got a Masters in
Business at New York no it's not like I
said no right
I mean again did you not think people
would find this out you know Pierce not
after I you're not wanting to be like a
reality TV no no I understand you know
if you if you were going on Celebrity
Apprentice which I went on right it
doesn't matter you can embellish stuff
about yourself nobody cares right but to
run for Congress of the United States
and to
just tell blatant lies about even your
academic record I'm just struck not
necessarily that a politician would lie
but that you would think no one would
find out well
I'll I'll humor you this I ran in 2020
for the same exact seat
um for Congress and I got away with it
then and I guess
why
well that's honest stupid so you thought
actually they don't they're not gonna
find out no I didn't think so but to to
that effect
um it's an embarrassing it's it's
humbling to have to admit your faults as
a human being and I you know I wish
genuinely if the media put the equal
amount of efforts and resources and I'm
not saying this as villainizing the
media but just let's keep it fair on all
435 members of the house and 100 members
of the Senate I think the American
people would have more clarity of who
represents them in Congress I'm not
saying I'm not going to say I listen I
think the media both at local level and
National level have pretty well been
forensic about everyone that's in
Congress right I mean maybe not to quite
the degree you've had to sustain it
because they knew with you they had
basically a wounded animal and if they
kept going long enough they've already
found a lot more right you know it's
human nature I mean you also claim to be
a Wall Street Hotshot who worked at
Goldman Sachs and Citigroup
um your CV again your resume boasted a
doubling revenue on a project at
Goldman's is any of that true so I this
is where the resume doesn't where I I
can defend my work career I work for
subsidiary groups and outside of those
companies you never worked at Goldman's
all Citigroup not at them as a direct
employee but I did work for them on the
lpgp side through conference organizing
fundraising uh uh attempts and marketing
of those functions but you weren't an
employee then you weren't no a Wall
Street hot shot right I I can argue I've
done very well in Wall Street
but not for Goldman's or Citigroup not
for not directly I mean neither of them
until the New York Times neither of them
like any record of you ever being
employed I've never worked directly for
them I was never on their books but I've
done work for them through other
companies that I work for yes sir you
can paint by a claim do you run a
foundation called friends of pets United
in New York and New Jersey that saved
two and a half thousand dogs and cats
over a five-year period is that true
that's true
um but I wasn't alone in in the
operation uh I had there was a multitude
of people we were all volunteers I was
the operator I was one of the I think we
were seven Founders if I'm not mistaken
between New York and New Jersey uh my
advocacy in animal uh welfare and animal
rights is that stems from my childhood
I've always very compassionate towards
animals I own four dogs at home they're
all rescues to to one sort I call it the
home of Misfits they're all unwanted
three legs heart murmur you know issues
like that and um now everybody is after
all the revelations about the
organization I wasn't in charge of any
of the I mean the weird thing is there
were no social media accounts for it no
time those were all deleted well there
were no the ones that anyone could find
no tax records no evidence of the
charity being registered in either New
York or New Jersey they did run one
fundraiser with the rescue group in New
Jersey in 2017. for which you charged a
50 entry fee but the group would stage
the event that had never received any
funds and I can attest that that is not
true the funds all ran through through
the group and the the post of the of the
facility was who was in charge of all of
our of our filings so this came to a
surprise as much what happened to the
tax records to the social media I I was
I wasn't in charge of any of that it was
never set up as a charity even well I I
wouldn't know that I was the operator I
was the guy putting cats out of the
streets into my car taking them together
would you say you're the operator of
this of this foundation and there's
literally no record of any of it
it doesn't doesn't there's much
credibility to your operational skills
like like I said I wasn't part of the
administrative part of the group we were
seven people everybody had their own
tasks my task was George go pick up this
dog go pick up this cat there's that was
my task go go deliver this adoption and
that that was my involvement with the
organization and I quite frankly did it
well I still get a lot of message
supports from people who adopted from
from us at During the period of time I
was involved who would have all the
records I don't know who would have all
the right one of the seven people that
you work with uh I would assume somebody
has records
there's tend to I mean I think some of
the stuff like that is an arguable Point
um potentially
some of the stuff about your family life
has caused I would say more offense if
as people believe it wasn't true and I
want to turn to something it's obviously
very personal to you and that's your own
mother
and this question of whether she was
working as you claimed in her office in
the South Tower of the Twin Towers on
September the 11th and then passed away
as you said a few years later when she
lost a battle to cancer now there is no
record of your mother Fatima devolda
ever having worked in the Twin Towers so
what's that true that's true why is
there no record doesn't work I don't
know where people are looking or what
they're looking for but there is
obviously no because of what happened
afterwards there's a record of everyone
that worked there there's no doubt about
who what
I'm sorry again well there's no doubt
about who there's no doubt who worked in
the buildings there was a full record
I'm very aware so the way the way that I
look at this and and I've I've rest this
case before and and respectfully please
I won't debate my mother's
um life as she's passed in 16 and I
think it's it's quite unsensitive for
everybody to want to rehash my mother's
Legacy uh well okay but hang on here's
what I would say to that
they're only doing that because you put
this on your campaign website I think if
a politician is going to use the fact of
his mother's death online as a result
she died a few years later it was
actually 15 years later she's going to
claim that she was in one of the towers
on the day of that terror attack I don't
think it's unreasonable for the media to
investigate that and there is simply no
evidence that your mother ever worked at
the World Trade Center at all and the
NBC News looked into this and said the
only known employer she had was at an
Imports business in Queens that folded
in 1994. New York Times said she worked
as a nurse in Brazil two genealogists
found documents that said your mother
returned to Brazil by September 2001
that she was actually not even in
America at the time she applied for a
visa to enter the US in 2003 stated in
the application she hadn't been in the
U.S since 1999. so all this points to
her not being any anywhere near the Twin
Towers on September those I do think it
matters because it's such an emotive
part of modern American history so I
simply ask you
did your mother work there or did you
just get that wrong no my mother was I
was 13 years old in September 11 2001 I
was in the United States so my mother
was here because she had full custody of
both her children so it's
so did she lie on her on her visa
application I I don't know I was a child
when these things were being done so I
have no clue and I have no recollection
of my mother having obtained a Visa if
she had a green card and and then
applied for citizenship later in life so
that's that's alien to me now you're
asking also things that I wouldn't know
I didn't know my mom had my mother had a
business in 1994. so I'm just like but
specifically on the point of why nobody
can find any evidence that your mother
worked at the World Trade Center at all
ever
could you just got this wrong
I mean just are you telling me that I
got wrong what my mother told me
I don't know is it possible she misled
you I don't believe so she wasn't one to
mislead me but there's no record that
she was there that day at all and
there's a record of every single person
that was in both those Towers I stay
convinced that that's the truth you
claimed in a conservative podcast in May
2022 that your grandparents survived the
Holocaust your campaign bio again
claimed that they fled persecution
during World War II and you told Fox
News that you have Ukrainian Heritage on
your mother's side now again multiple
family records so your maternal
grandparents were born in Brazil and a
genealogist told CNN there's no sign of
Jewish and or Ukrainian Heritage and no
indication of name changes along the way
so
this is the one that I I'll battle To My
Grave to the point that I've already
ordered
um those DNA test kits and I've done
four of them so far and I'm just waiting
for their returns and I'm very curious
to share those with everybody because I
grew up with with this the story was my
grandfather was born in
Ukraine when it was part of the Soviet
Union migrated to Belgium met my
grandmother in the fort in 1940 or 1941
they fled to Brazil where they falsified
a lot of their documents to claim they
were born there and now look we're
talking about a time in history where
this was a very common occurrence in the
name of survival and it this has
happened to other people and they were
able to uncover it and then apology
letters were written I've seen this
happen in the community in the Jewish
community in organizations and I I will
be that same story because I'm working
on that right now okay but you would
understand that if that wasn't true if
your grandparents hadn't survived the
Holocaust that would be a pretty awful
thing why would I play with that right
that's you know I'm I'm one of the most
staunch pro-israel most staunch
pro-judaism people in Congress so you
claim to be Jewish but you're not Jewish
I never claim to be Jewish I've always
made I've always made a party favorite
joke pretend to be Jewish half Jewish a
proud American Jew a Latino Jew and a
non-observant Jew they're all direct
quotes from so you're not you're
Catholic I think I've I'm a Catholic
Pierce I've always made this as a party
favorite joke and it's I've done it on
stages across what's funny claiming
you're Jewish no no not falsely claiming
I'm Jewish I would always say I'm I was
raised Catholic but I come from a Jewish
family so that makes me Jewish but again
it's always been a party favor
everybody's always laughed and now that
everybody's canceling me everybody's
pounding down for about the place just
because you're not Jewish well I never
said I was I've always I I've said you
were and I would always say but my
grandparents are Jewish on my mother's
side so I'm Jewish that was always a
joke everybody used to laugh it up I
said it to a room with a thousand people
in November people were hysterically
laughing it was funny to them they loved
it I don't think Jewish people find it
funny they were Jewish I was in a room
with the Republicans people find it
funny the U.S congressman he's a
Catholic with no apparent background of
any Jewish Heritage whatsoever other
than you say you have it no one can find
it I think a lot of Jewish people would
find that offensive uh I I begged it for
when we were at the RJC in November the
problem you have Congress it seems to me
is that you admit to certain big lies
and then you deny other big lies and the
problem people have is they don't know
when you're lying and when you're
telling the truth I'm not even sure now
because how can I be like I said because
you've claimed on campaign buyers you
went to this school and this volleyball
team and achieved this degree in Big
Wall Street big hitter and all these
things turned out not to be true so when
you now look me in the eye and say well
actually no I you know I'm this is true
I don't know what to believe no I
understand and that look that's a
position I've put myself in right my
credibility is what what I'm going to
have a hard time in a long road to
recover and I stand clear and I stand
certain that I'll be able to do that
okay let me ask you this in an interview
um with New York Public Radio following
your election you said you lost four
employees in the Pulse Nightclub mass
shooting in 2016. I reported on that as
horrendous but none of the 49 victims at
that Orlando Club
what any of the companies that you've
named in your biography you said you
lost four employees those are the people
not not for people who who worked for
you for employees bad choice of words
and I'm not the only one guilty of that
but that's essentially the The Raw Story
of what happened no one could find any
connection between any of the 49 victims
and any evil companies so where where is
the evidence for that I I would venture
calling the company and asking them the
people of the media have done that no
they haven't they haven't been able to
to attain any contact with the company
well nobody can find any evidence it is
true
like I said I'm reporting based on what
was reported to us that morning
you angrily denied this is another one
where it's quite interesting because I
don't know why you would deny it when it
was clearly turned out to be true
um particularly after all the fury that
had gone on but you angry deny being a
drag artist after a Brazilian drag queen
posted a picture of herself with you you
said the most recent Obsession from the
media claiming I'm a drag queen or
performed as a drag queen is
categorically false it is it's not
though is it Pierce save the picture oh
hold on I go out so so if I was a drag
queen I was the poorest drag queen in
the world because I had one outfit in
one day the shortest lives you're saying
you were a good drag queen I'm just
saying you couldn't even dressed up in
Drive once oh sorry okay there's like me
saying Rudy Julia I'm not a murderer I
only kill one guy I understand but Rudy
Giuliani dressed up in drag it's not a
water boundary yeah is he a drag queen
I've got a lot of questions Rudy Julia
that's my point you dressed up in drag
look here's my point I know here's my
boy why deny it I didn't deny why attack
the obsessive media for publishing a
truth because the media is not telling
the truth the media is portraying
America they are they they're they're
portraying to the American people that I
mean drag performer career drag queen
which is offensive to drag queens by the
way and I'm pretty sure most of the drag
queens of New York here's what they
think they're not just because you've
admitted he dressed up in drag but a
2011 Wikipedia bio for a user named
Anthony devolda one of your pseudonyms
claim that following a successful drag
career you landed roles on Disney
Channel shows like Hannah Montana and a
role in a movie called The Invasion
starring Uma Thurman now either you did
that under your student name which you
have told me you use well somebody has
gone away and created their own
Wikipedia bio using one of your
pseudonyms to invent all this why would
they do that I had no notion idea or
even I didn't know this Wikipedia page
existed why would someone invent you and
pretend to be you 2011. everyone knows
who you are I'm making this very clear I
have no clue I have no ownership of that
paper right
wait there's someone here this is this
is 12 years ago pierce my point I never
a never tried to be an actor never
pretended to be an actor B I was never a
career drag queen I did once I dress up
in drag once we've seen photograph I
mean is it likely I mean again I don't
care if you dress up in drag there's a
Millennials to me no okay look here's my
question for you a it's unlikely you did
that only once if I may be sober you can
say that it's just that only once have
we got photographic evidence right
Pierce I think it's it's it's just to me
it's almost amusing that people are
trying to fight me of being something
that I'm not that quite frankly if I
were to say oh yeah I'm a drag queen
that would probably give me a Redemption
points which I'm I'm not willing to take
it because then I'd be admitting to a
lie just to cover myself for the media
so I feel like what you guys want me to
do is admit to something I haven't done
let me tell you what I want you to do I
simply want you to be honest I don't
give a damn no well that's what I'm
trying to tell you well listen I think
I'm being I'm being very strict you have
come in here right and you've sat
opposite me and we're going through all
this and you're giving me answers right
and that's your credit to do it you
didn't have to so I appreciate you doing
it but the you reportedly told donors
you were a producer on Spider-Man and
Broadway is that true no I never said
that not true
I never said that I'm still I'm still
trying to ask I've asked the reporters
tell me who the donors were that I
actually that's kind of go down through
I never said to anybody I produced a
Broadway show and if you look at the
Timeline I think I would have been 21
years old well you claimed a lot of
things in your life Congressman
um one month or if you were elected you
claimed on a Brazilian podcast you'd
already suffered an assassination
attempt and that you described being
mugged on Fifth Avenue in 2021. I was
mugged on Fifth Avenue in 2021 was there
any police records no there was no
police right you didn't report it there
was no pull there was no police in sight
2021 this was a Zombie Land out here oh
but did you report it no I did not I got
up went into the car defeated upset
because I had experience one of the most
important things they took my briefcase
and my shoes who did two guys
on Fifth Avenue that's it I was crossing
the street not fifth pardon me Sixth and
if that reported fifth sixth because I
would I worked on the fifth on 55th and
Sixth Street
you know Pierce I don't know I felt
defeated embarrassed I'm a six foot tall
guy that couldn't defend himself from a
briefcase in my shoes do you know how
humiliating that is do you know how fear
how much fear gets instilled in you I
just finished running across the street
into the garage where the my car was
parked picked up my car and left
I'm lucky my phone was in my pocket so I
could you know just do the the phone
payment on the or else I wouldn't have
money to take my car what about the
assassination attempt when was that it
wasn't an assassination it was a death
threat this is poorly translated
Portuguese to English language it was a
death threat it was several deaths
nobody tried to kill you no and I've
never claimed somebody tried to kill me
these were several we had a several
series of death threats following so
this Brazilian podcast has you saying
already suffered an assassination
attempt that's well that's been badly
translated this is poor translation so
we go back and we listen to the original
please do I I I I wouldn't have you
saying you'd already suffered I I
encourage you yeah yeah so it wouldn't
have you saying those words it has me
clearly saying that I suffered an uh uh
um death threats throughout the process
of running for office something along
those lines but no assassination okay
here's the thing here here's the thing
you may as well just be completely
honest now well that's what I mean I'm
not going to respond yourself to the
public to their Mercy to say
I've made up all this stuff about myself
right I'm incredibly sorry and I fall on
the sword of of your forgiveness because
you're now facing eight different
investigations who knows where they're
all going to lead there's all these
questions about your financing your
campaign campaign expenses all of it on
the face of it looks dodgy but your
biggest problem is going to be
persuading people of what the truthful
answers are I have a question for you
though and if if I may eight you say
there's eight investigations I haven't
seen a formal investigation be open yet
the media keeps portraying to the
American people that I'm being
investigated through the Wazoo and
that's all I keep asking at least report
it factually just please tell the people
because what what this alludes to is
people thinking that I'm a criminal that
the doj is coming after me and then we
start receiving again death threats at
my office just two weeks ago we had a
credible death threat from a man with a
rap sheet as long as you can think of
from the state of Florida calling us and
leaving it the man was so psychotic he
left a detailed voicemail saying that he
was going to get a baseball bat bash my
husband's brains in and I was going to
watch it then he was going to Splatter
mine all over the floor and he wasn't
going to stop until there was nothing
left
or the genius left a voicemail on my
office number we sent its Capitol Police
they did their job they found him he has
a rap sheet he's been arrested in jobs I
I don't know where the for the point of
the investigation is but I know who he
is I have his rap sheet the Capitol
Police know who he is this is something
that's highly concerning to the safety
of me and my family it's all the media
whipping up the anger against you
there's so much sensationalism right
well that's why it's been it's been good
for Clarity on this
one of the more serious allegations
against you I felt was that you stole
money from a disabled veteran who
contacted you to help fund life-saving
surgery for his service dog this is a
man called Richard ostoff he says that
you raise cash on GoFundMe but refused
to hand over the money and AP says the
FBI is now investigating this what is
the truth of this I've never met this
man
a lot like I've been abundantly clear I
feel for him I feel for his story I am
as compassionate and as passionate about
helping veterans and animals as is the
next guy I when I read this it just it
hit me like a bag of bricks because I
don't know him and most people who know
me who truly know me Pierce knows that
if he had met me his dog would have
received the surgery he wouldn't be
homeless
the fact that he was homeless and
anybody trying to help him address
wouldn't address the homeless issue was
a bigger problem for me and I mean that
wholeheartedly so you never set up a
GoFundMe page
I've set up dozens of GoFundMe no one
will find one that relates to let me
make it very clear I've set up numerous
GoFundMe Pages throughout the years for
for animals and needs many of them who
were not managed by me they were managed
by other people but because I was the
main account holder on the Facebook page
it would all go you're not denying there
could be a GoFundMe I'm not denying
there could be a GoFundMe page but I'm
not happen to that money if there is
like I said I'm not denying if there's a
GoFundMe page and if they're going to
present me with one I'm not going to
deny that but I've never met him I've
never took on this case and I never took
the money from his dog
just about your your
I guess your private life to a degree
which has been put through the mincer as
you know
um it seems from everything that's
appeared in the meeting it's your chance
to clarify this you'll now you're
married
although there's no record of that
marriage having happened I'll actually
show you the the wedding certificate
I was married under on November 30th
2021 where in Nassau County so it's all
registered there yeah because no one's
found any records yeah it's there it's
and it's there okay and you were
previously married to a woman I was
married to a woman yes so how long
it was on and off a couple of years it
was a personal private messy part of my
life and something that I refuse and I I
will not and respectfully and I hope you
don't take this personal but I will not
indulge anybody to get into my personal
life because it's irrelevant to what my
job as a legislator is my second my
personal sex life is not something that
I'm going to use for entertainment and
no tabloid here's what I would say I
listen I agree with you but I would say
that someone who has made a a big play I
think of being the first openly gay
Republican who was non-incumbent to be
voted into Congress you know you've made
no secret of your pride of being that
that's about your sexuality so I think
it's reasonable for the media to just
try and establish what you're so life
has been life I never campaigned on that
ever on being gay we talked proudly
about it I when asked but that was the
media's obsession with this campaign was
oh it's the first time two gay men ever
go head to head for you Congress but I
never campaigned it wasn't a campaign
issue it wasn't even a footnote on my
website obviously ask you I mean do you
feel you've always been a gay man no no
I my life was it wasn't straightforward
I I was very much in love with someone
and we got married and it just didn't
work out
did she know that you might be gay I
don't think so no
and it got messy Pierce like I said I'm
not going to rehash my sex life on
television what reaction have you had to
being a gay Republican Congressman do
Republicans have never discriminated
against me matter of fact it's the
Democrats who often come after me for
being a gay Republican and they use that
to to criticize me it seems to me I mean
you've been very honest there about your
private life
you know and I don't want to break over
at all I'm not going to do any any
further but you have been it seems to be
very honest and I would applaud you for
that but it begs the question why not be
as honest about everything else in your
life you've got a lot of people calling
you the world's worst liar and political
history that's right one into trash I
beg differ because Joe Biden's in the
white house but that's just me I've seen
you tweet that I've seen you that's just
me you know Mitt Romney one of the
senior Republican Senators came up to
you instead of Union said you shouldn't
be glad handing people down the front
you should be out the back hiding in
shame and he also said that you should
Stand Down
wouldn't be the first time somebody told
me to shut up and go to the back of the
room Pearson it's not going to be the
last is it right though Congressman that
you should be able to have told so many
lies and remain in Congress or do you
think the American public are entitled
to somebody who is more truthful sitting
in one of the great seats of power in
the country I think that the Americans
who voted for me will get to judge me in
two years and they make that ultimate
decision not the Talking Heads not
politicians not Party leaders do you
think you want to run again I don't know
I and this has let me make this very
clear if you talk to people who knew me
before any of this ever happened they
always ask so what's next I said I don't
know if I'm going to run for re-election
that's always been a thought I I believe
in term limits that's number one number
two I came to this shop I wanted to see
if I could accomplish the bare minimum
for the American people which was my
thought you come into the shop very
naive thinking that you're going to
conquer the world and you're going to do
everything good for the American people
and when you hit Washington DC you learn
that it's just not so straightforward
and that's what I want I want to be able
to overcome the political red tape of
Washington DC but what do you say to
people watching this you go all right of
course you do that's fine but what about
all the lies you've told I mean would
you stare down the camera and just
apologize I've I've looked inside the
camera and I've said sorry and I have no
problem saying sorry and asking for
forgiveness of the American people
watching at home and everyone abroad
because I think that if you can if you
can
ask for forgiveness and have the
humility to accept and admit your errors
I think that's the first step now it's
amazing how I don't get that same
courtesy like everyone else does
ever and you've been through this Pierce
it seems like there's a different
there's people who are granted that
opportunity to apologize and redeem
themselves and there's people who are
thrown into the fire pit and and the
media and everyone else around them are
hell-bound on making sure that that
person's life is hell I'm in the latter
part I don't get the opportunity to ask
for forgiveness and and gain forgiveness
from people or sympathy you supported
Donald Trump over what many call the big
lie about his stolen election I don't
think he had the election stolen from
him but have you heard from Donald Trump
no I have not not at all no
have you heard from other senior
Republicans supporting you I have many
Republicans who have been supportive I I
have a great support system within the
party of people who are you know walking
me through this very difficult time in
my life and they've been you know Mitch
McConnell uh I've never met Mitch
McConnell I saw him at the State of the
Union Kevin McCarthy's been a great
leader for the Republican conference and
he does he think you should carry on
I haven't had that discussion with him
no no can you go around as George Santos
now and persuade other politicians to
help you with stuff or are they all like
you know what just get cleared or we're
not interested so I have two bills that
we're working on right now and that
we're getting uh folks to subscribe to
and we're working on good bills for the
American people
and I'm not having a hard time I mean
it's I'm not going to say it's easy but
it's not abnormal from the difficulties
that every other politician has trying
to get people to subscribe to their
ideas
and I'm navigating the process well the
one difference between me and the
ordinary person is I come from struggle
I come from abject poverty as I've
always said so my life is do you like I
do how can I be sure well I think that
the proof is in the pudding both my
parents were immigrants I suppose I
don't know I don't know what the pudding
is oh I'll tell you what the pudding is
both my parents or immigrants I was born
in a public City Hospital in 1988 in
Jackson Heights queens in a basement
apartment where I I I beg differ that I
think the rats were bigger than me when
I was born so and true stories I've I've
submitted enough evidence on that I I
say this everything can you give the
American people you're not going to
carry online
I've made that abundantly clear that I
want to be the most transparent member
of Congress and deliver the most
transparent everything that goes on I
look if I'm flying stops now it stopped
a long time ago well Congressman I'll
say this about you you came in to Piers
Morgan uncensored and you face the music
and I appreciate that I appreciate you
and I'll be interested to see what the
public make because in the end it's not
down to me what I think of you or anyone
else in the media it's down to the
American people whether if you decide to
run again whether they're prepared to
actually vote for you again yep I think
uh like like I've always said this is
going to be decided by the people who
hired me not no one else so that's when
I'm going to face the music
thanks for coming in thank you sir I
appreciate you